في هذه الصور المباشر
الاحتجاجات ضد التغييرات القضائيه واقاله
وزير
الدفاعات مستمره لا تزال حشود المتظاهرين
تزيد وتملا الساحات في القدس ورام الله
فضلا عن تل ابيب ايضا هناك محاولات من
الشرطه لمنع المتظاهرين كشفت شرطه
الاسرائيليه عن 80 الف متظاهر على الاقل
يطوقون الكنيست نذهب الى الكنيسه من امامه
تحديدا تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه لانك
الغاصي لانا مرحبا بك ما هي اخر التطورات
الحشود تستمر في التواجد في هذه الساعات
اهلا بك يعني فعليا الحشود تتزايد منذ
صباح اليوم يتوافد عشرات الالاف من مدن
مختلفه الى القدس من تل ابيب من حيفا من
بئر السبع من مناطق مختلفه قاموا باستخدام
ايضا القطارات العامه للتوجه الى القدس
والتجمع هنا كما ترون امام الكنيست يعني
ان استطاع ايضا عبد مساعدتي حتى تقومون
برؤيه اعداد كبيره من المتظاهرين الان هم
خرجوا ضد هذه التعديلات القضائيه وضد
نتنياهو حتى يعني على ما يبدو ان ايضا
هناك غضب ولكن في نفس الوقت شعور
بالانتصار من قبل هؤلاء المتظاهرين حيث
يعني باتت مطالبهم يعني
باتت مطالبهم فعليا تتجه الى التنفيذ هناك
مخاوف مخاوف كبيره في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الان ويعني محاوله لاقناع نتنياهو بالخروج
والاعلان ربما تاجيل هذه التعديلات
القضائيه ولكن المتظاهرين يقولون بانهم لن
يرضوا فقط بتاجيل هذه التعديلات القضائيه
الى ما بعد الاعياد اليهوديه او حتى بعد
استقلال اسرائيل اي بعد شهر من الان ولكن
هم يقولون نحن نريد الغاء هذه التعديلات
القضائيه بشكل نهائي لان هذه التعديلات
القضائيه من شانها ان تؤدي اسرائيل حسب ما
وصفوها يعني تعديلات الديكتاتوريه
وايضا كان هناك اضراب شامل او اضراب في
عديد من المجالات انضم عدد من الطلاب من
الجامعات ايضا من البنوك من التعليم هناك
عمال ايضا من ماكدونالدز وهو ايضا شركه
عالميه يعرفها الجميع قاموا باغلاق
متاجرهم لمده اربع ساعات في جميع انحاء
بلاد البلاد يعني نحن نتحدث ايضا الى
انضمام وكان هناك مطار بن غوريون الدولي
الى هذا الاضراب